do you know where we are this is earth
after earth this movie is directed and
co-written by m night shyamalan the
director who was once known to be the
next alfred hitchcock and now everybody
thinks he should burn in hell honestly i
really like the [ __ ] movie i know
nobody else does but this critic says
[ __ ] all the other critics i'll start
off by first acknowledging yes this has
a more personal meaning to me i've had
to do a lot of growing in my life a lot
of it had to do with a lot of the
messages and philosophies that are being
communicated in this film but regardless
of that i would still consider this to
be a really good movie will smith and
jaden smith this is not the pursuit of
happiness part two like i thought it was
gonna be basically will smith is this
emotionally closed off dude who is known
to be fearless will smith has a kid
jayden smith who has a lot of fear and
is very emotional so the character
growth they have to go through is one
has to learn how to feel the other one
has to learn how to not be so emotional
and to face his fears and i think they
honestly both do a good job at it
they're giving will smith crap for not
being the charismatic stuff that he
normally is but why would this character
be mr funny charming guy jaden smith
honestly he does a fine job in this film
he's not the terrible actor that
everyone's talking about yes he's not
the best thing in the world but he's
good enough the main thing i loved about
this was the story i love science
fiction i love survival tale movies and
this film takes a concept like that but
is more of like a parable for all the
messages this film is strongly
about its messages and its philosophies
it's not so much about being this big
crazy science fiction action adventure
film no it's about these a father and
son relationship it's about having to
survive and it's about what mentality it
takes to get through this journey it's a
great metaphor for anyone who wants to
accomplish anything in life and will
smith he does a good job a very good job
remember when he used to have vulcan
ears i just love the story of having to
face your trauma in order to let it go
so you can grow as a person yes it does
move slower than most movies but i don't
want to consider this a slow movie i
would consider a movie that more so
takes its time but it builds tension and
allows for other elements to be at play
this movie is basically a science
fiction backdrop for its messages
there's also some great cinematography
in here there's awesome visual effects
not all the time but a lot of the time
there is and last thing i have to say
hollywood is really making me not want
to live on planet earth anymore and i
know what you're thinking it's not
because of the jews i like jews and i
also like gays and blacks you might be
wondering what the point of all that is
honestly i don't [ __ ] know let me get
straight to the point here all in all i
gotta say and i'm gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] for this after earth got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for after earth why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me what is your favorite movie
about earth sucking and if you want to
see a more in-depth review of after
earth go ahead and check out my show
called reasons to see that i do with my
buddy jerry he's the white guy right
there with the beard and all that [ __ ]
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
is out
go ahead and subscribe to my channel
take a knee